hey friends I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel today we're talking about battle
royale not the movie that was released
in the year 2000 based on a book that
released in 1999 no we're talking about
video games the pub cheese and the
fortnight's of the world both of which
are declining don't get me wrong
fortnight is still making more money in
a month than I will probably make in my
entire life its growth is just according
to a report published by Super daughter
research finally slowing down which to
me is a no-brainer but when it comes to
this conversation which I think was
inevitable I want to say that no I don't
think this decline means the death of
battle royale is finally here and we're
finally seeing the end of a dumb fat and
everyone was stupid and unoriginal for
chasing pub G as I keep seeing people
say on Twitter on that same note I don't
feel that we should be mad at Call of
Duty or battlefield are making their own
battle royale modes as a lot of the
internet seemed to be when those modes
were announced I ultimately don't think
that adding battle royale modes to games
is just chasing a fad that's going to
burn and fizzle out it's more of a
natural evolution of multiplayer games
and industry experts wager that we're
not going to stop seeing it anytime soon
so for anyone who doesn't know I feel
like we need to throw in some history
here
if we're going broad it goes back to
goldeneye on the 64 which I played a lot
of some of you might remember a mode
called You Only Live Twice where
everyone had two lives but it was still
a lost man standing game mode where you
spawned you collected weapons and then
you tried to kill everyone else that was
there Unreal Tournament had a similar
mode so did counter-strike but it wasn't
until Hunger Games debuted in cinemas in
2012 that we saw a larger scale battle
royale gaming from the modding community
by larger scale I literally mean larger
like more players bigger Maps first to
make hunger games I think was the
Minecraft modding community an era still
loads a popular Hunger Games maps for
Minecraft they started popping up just
off the first movie came out and after
that we got the popular ARMA 2 mod dayz
and then dayz itself and rust and an
odometer mod in h1z1 and pub GE and then
fortnight and then also radical Heights
and like a bunch of other Indians it was
always a lot of iteration as so much of
the games industry is
levena once said to me that he thought
that Bioshock was really just an
elaborate reskin of half-life and that's
coming from the guy who made Bioshock
but I think the difference between the
more long-term half life style
iterations we see in Singh apply of PS
campaigns and Battle Royale iteration is
really just that battle royale blow up
so quickly and started from mods or
Indies rather than triple-a games so it
felt to the public more like a dumb
trend babji is sold over 50 million
copies fortnight makes over 100 million
dollars a month like dramatically over
that on some months even if it's still
free-to-play and broke wild records for
the highest number of concurrent players
and the highest number of concurrent
viewers on Twitch and of course as soon
as the money was made and the record
started rolling in activision mea jumped
on it and started making their own
battle royale modes the appeal for
publishers goes beyond money though
battle royale actually happens to be
fairly easy to make according to a lot
of devs basically you can just put
players into a box and randomly spawn
weapons every match meaning you don't
really have to worry about balance which
is one of the more complicated facets of
multiplayer development you also don't
really need to generate that much
content the appeal of battle royale is
really just the tension of survival the
longer you live the strong you tend to
get because you're collecting battle
loot the tenser it gets because you're
closer to winning that appeal functions
by itself by design without devs needing
to make any elaborate narrative
additions it's also just that a lot of
the entertainment is player generated
which was especially the case of pubsey
and dayz before it basically people are
playing these games to the experiences
they're having with everyone else on the
server and that's a lot of people rather
than for the experiences the developers
have to implement though I will say I
think fortnight does a great job of
implementing events and content anyway
so for the developers and publishers it
makes a lot of sense that we're going to
get more and more battle royale and with
all of that context I think the
strangest thing about the conversations
surrounding battle royale is that we're
looking at it as a new genre rather than
as a new multiplayer mode team
deathmatch has existed since the 90s and
even back then it was spoken about in a
pretty similar way to how we're talking
about battle royale right now or how we
were I don't know a year ago John Romero
who worked on the land multiplayer mode
for doom said sure it was fun to shoot
months
but ultimately these were soulless
creatures controlled by a computer
now gamers could play against
spontaneous human beings opponents who
could think and strategize and scream we
can kill each other if we can get this
done this is going to be the [ __ ]
coolest game that the planet Earth has
ever [ __ ] seen in its entire history
he was the one who said this where's I'm
just reporting on the swears please
don't hate me YouTube but he was kind of
right but now almost every multiplayer
game that's out there has game is
fighting against spontaneous human
beings king of the hill and
capture-the-flag started out in the
1980s and cole was and bana cat
respectively now they're in FPS staple
franchises like halo but RL is just our
next FPS staple multiplayer mode an
edition that's fun and if it's in more
games I just kind of see no harm there
man I'd probably have liked it if more
games had the man with the Golden Gun
from Goldeneye because that rule so if
every multiplayer IP is going to have a
battle royale mode because they can and
probably should the question for me
isn't the stuff that I'm seeing online
that's along the lines of how are they
going to compete against one another
because that's really just the same as
asking how a battlefield and Call of
Duty as a whole going to compete and
it's also not when a player is going to
get bored of this mode or when is it
going to feel oversaturated because
we're not bored a team deathmatch
my question is in the long run what
happens to pub G and fortnight of course
what night does have the save the world
mode it's not just about a rail but I am
really curious to see how those two
staples adjust to multiplayer
juggernauts in the industry taking the
entire hook and making it a single mode
in a broader experience basically I
think it's going to be a really
interesting challenge for epic and pub G
Cole rather than a challenge for
battlefield I'll call it or just anyone
else who throws it into their repertoire
of multiplayer modes if the industry
goes ahead with making it a staple mode
like I suspect it will it's also just
really convenient for the mobis out
there like doto league even smite heroes
that Moga isn't much harder to replicate
in other multiplayer games and I think
the same also applies for analogs you
can't just drop that into another genre
battle round kind of came it was always
going to be a one-trick pony and I
imagine
companies do that I don't know but hey
I'm also really thankful that Brendan
green and pubsey Cole sort of pioneered
this game-mode obviously including all
of that history but that's the thing
that we have now because I personally
still really enjoy it but of course my
theory here may not be what happens just
my theory and I am very interested to
see what does end up happening let me
know what you guys think I suspect that
my opinion on this is an unpopular one I
don't know
it should also mention that I do imagine
there will be a coal player base who
continues to play fortnight for a very
long time but I do think that they have
to adapt and and shift and grow pretty
much at the end of this year anyway that
is it from me today you guys sorry that
I went a little bit between uploads I
was my birthday this week so I just kind
of wanted to take a break I am also
going to Japan very soon I am super
excited I'll probably be posting lots of
photos over on Instagram if you guys
want to join me on my Japanese
adventures and with that I'm Ilana and I
will see you guys next time